this is supposed to make working out fun
a pair of glasses a smartphone and a nap
give athletes the chance to dive into a
virtual reality behind it or two
inventors from Munich their baby goes on
the market in the spring for seven
thousand euros this house without really
noticing in other words it's no longer a
chore instead you shoot down a few
drones and chase your friends over the
mountains or fly through the Grand
Canyon and end up fitter Grand Canyon
want an office to fit our oats for help
filming yourself playing is now a big
part of many sports the Berlin startup
love has invented a tripod for
smartphones and small cameras that keeps
images steady even when snowboarding or
skiing they are in three hundred sixty
thousand euros through crowdfunding and
pre-orders the invention hit store
shelves in May we've always filmed our
exploits on snowboards and skateboards
using action cams but the results were
shaky there wasn't anything available
that worked for us so we decided to
create our own solution I know losing to
finger the ESPO isn't just a meeting
place for global players but also for
smaller manufacturers and there's a lot
happening in apparel the French company
pictures organic clothing is committed
to recycling at least fifty percent of
its products are made from recycled
materials
for example a ski helmet made of a
polymer obtained from corn plants and
old car interiors coochie-coo we found
that our customers don't necessarily buy
for environmental reasons or because of
the styles for them it's a matter of
lifestyle they want to have fun and get
a good product wowcity friendly tree
cool it was accessible one invention
visitors can get pumped about as
inflatable windsurfing equipment which
goes from flat to full in 90 seconds
it's especially suitable for beginners
or leisure travellers who want to save
space in their car and it's a snip at
350 euros and if skateboarding is too
old-school for your tastes the hip new
thing is wheeling at California firm
plans to bring it to europe in the
spring but it'll set you back a whopping
17 hundred euros